It's great to welcome to the program today,
Jason Goldwater, who is a California attorney
who represents small and medium sized businesses
throughout Southern California, advises businesses,
unemployment and labor issues and best practices.
Jason, great to have you on today.
Thanks, David.
Great to be here.
So let's start with in figuring out, you know,
every day we hear this number of billions
of dollars is going out.
Everybody's getting twelve hundred bucks.
Unemployment's being boosted by six hundred
dollars.
The paycheck protection plan, billions and
billions and billions of dollars are going
out.
Let's start talking through what's been announced
and what has happened.
So the twelve hundred dollars were close to
two out of the three weeks that they said
it would take for that money to start going
out.
Is there any system yet for people who did
not get direct deposit of their tax returns
last year to say, here's how you get me my
money?
Are any of these infrastructures in place
at this point?
So they are not.
The IRS has said that they're going to create
a portal on their website where people can
essentially go on and say, I want my money
going to this man account or going to this
address.
So that has not happened yet, even though
the private sector could probably do this
in under a day.
The IRS, I'd be very surprised if they managed
to do it by next week.
And don't forget, it's not just people who
didn't receive direct deposit, but maybe people
whose bank account information has changed,
whose addresses have changed.
So none of that infrastructure is in place.
And like I said, I'd be very surprised if
that happens by next week.
I think probably one to two months is more
likely.
So two weeks ago, they said in three weeks,
the people who have the same direct deposit
information as when they filed their tax returns
would start getting their twelve hundred dollars.
The people who need to, as you say, provide
banking information might have had a change
of address, et cetera.
It could be three more weeks.
That sounds like you're saying it's all a
little bit optimistic right now.
Well, all right.
I mean, unless the IRS is going to start blindly
sending out twelve hundred dollars to bank
accounts that, you know, just because something
was correct on a 2010 tax return doesn't mean
that bank account has some effect can be closed.
I mean, they could be sending twelve hundred
dollars really to a bank account that's not
open to someone else's bank account.
So I don't see how this is going to happen
unless people first have a chance to confirm
that the information the IRS has is still
correct from the information the IRS had potentially
a year and a half ago.
OK, so now let's talk about the the supplemented
the the both bolstered boosted unemployment.
The idea was unemployment is, of course, managed
at the state level.
Massachusetts has its system.
Illinois has its system, et cetera.
There are different state level benefits that
are the maximum benefits available to people.
The federal government announced they would
be supplementing those benefits with up to
six hundred dollars per week in additional
funding.
Now, I know a lot of people who have been
who filed for unemployment in the last three
weeks, a 16 million people did.
They, as of now, are not getting anything
additional above and beyond what the state
provides.
What do we know about the rollout of that?
So as you just mentioned, everything is occurring
on a state by state basis.
All I can tell you is there there's very there
was very little information, actually, about
what is happening.
We know that there is supposed to be this
additional $600.
We don't know when it's going to be implemented.
As you mentioned, each state has a different
system.
And on top of that, the care is also provided
that people who are self-employed, independent
contractors, for example, getting economy
workers would also be eligible for unemployment
assistance.
Now, typically, if someone is self-employed
or an independent contractor, there's typically
a voluntary unemployment insurance program
that they can pay into to be eligible.
So the CARES Act does away with that.
But the problem is there is not a single state
yet.
As far as I'm aware, that has implemented
guidance as to how exactly this program will
work for people in the gig economy, for example,
people who are self-employed and who is eligible
and how they're going to get their money.
And right now, the guidance essentially is
for people to go out and apply and they'll
try to figure it out later.
And of course, it is important for people
to get applications then, because the applications
will be processed in the order that they received
and they will not get the unemployment insurance
until.
And so essentially for a period before they
apply.
So I know some people in the Midwest who you
know, there's a lot of states in the Midwest
that have they don't have very robust unemployment
systems.
So they are maxing out sometime.
Three hundred and fifty dollars a week.
They're counting on that extra six hundred
that the federal government says is coming
and it's not there and they're not getting
any answers from the state unemployment departments
as to when that's going to start.
Yeah, I'm in California, I can tell you, maxes
out at $450 per week.
So you can just think with our cost of living
in San Francisco and Los Angeles and San Diego,
450 a week does not go very far at all.
And you're absolutely right that the six additional
six hundred dollars absolutely critical.
But the state employment offices are used
to processing a certain number of applications
per week.
And as you've pointed out, we've had an additional
50 and 60 million people applying for unemployment.
And the infrastructure is just not there to
process those kinds of numbers.
So let's now.
Oh, sorry.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
But Jason, there is one thing I wanted to
mention a lot of people are not aware of.
So this varies state by state.
But a lot of people who are underemployed
right now, who have had their hours cut may
be eligible for unemployment assistance again,
depending on the state, depending on what
their earning level is currently.
So it's important for people who are underemployed,
who've had their hours cut to go ahead and
apply for unemployment insurance as well.
So then we've got the programs for businesses.
And part of this is the payment protection
plan.
There's a couple of other programs and elements
to these programs that are available every
day.
I'm sorry, what is it?
Elements of medical.
Yes, elements.
Elements of funding.
So every day at a press cut press briefing,
Mike Pence or Donald Trump will say something
like, you know, a million people have applied
or three thousand lenders are now taking applications
or we have processed 10 billion dollar every
day.
It's different and the terminology being used
is different.
Our business is actually getting money yet.
Have businesses received any money yet under
that program?
So I am not aware personally of any businesses
that who received money under the Paycheck
Protection Program or the emergency or economic
injury disaster loan program.
So that doesn't mean it hasn't happened.
That just doesn't.
It just means that the rollout has not been
very widespread.
There are still some banks like Citibank,
which is my bank, that are not even accepting
applications and the money is already going
to run out.
I mean, Bank of America on its own, I think
as of a few days ago, they process, I think,
over 20 percent of the total funding available
for the PDP program.
Meanwhile, Citibank is not even accepting
applications.
So the whole again, the rollout here has been
unfortunately a little bungled.
It's increasingly seeming to me.
And again, I hope that things can get reopened
sooner than later as it's safe.
Never beyond what is safe.
But I hope things get going as soon as this
is safe.
It's starting to seem like a lot of these
funds may not even get to people before the
reopening starts if things continue on this
path.
Yeah, I mean, you know, it's not just a question
of reopening, but but by the time we're through
with the lockdown, frankly, there will be
so much job loss.
And unfortunately, the job loss really is
not just affecting at this point the hospitality
industries or the restaurant industries or
economic industries, but it's affecting all
the other industries indirectly.
I mean, I can tell you as a lawyer, for example,
the courts are closed.
So any laws were in litigation have no work
right now, even if they did.
Businesses don't really want to be spending
money on lawyers.
I mean, this is affecting every segment, every
segment of society right now in the last bit
of time we have.
Is there any thing we have not talked about
either in terms of programs or in terms of
what individuals can or should be doing that
you think is important for people to know?
So I did want to talk briefly about the programs
that are available because there have been
some changes to the program since they were
initially announced.
So the first program that's available is the
Economic Injury Disaster Loan Grant.
So the bill said and the Small Business Administration
initially said that these were going to be
ten thousand dollar grants.
So the SBA has now changed that.
Now it's going to be one thousand dollar grant
per employee that the business employs up
to ten thousand dollars.
So you can imagine a lot of small businesses
may only be getting one or two thousand dollars.
For example, those loans will be processed
in three days.
I don't know of any I mean, the link the application
has been up probably for a week and a half
or two weeks.
And I don't know anyone who's gotten that.
You can apply directly for that on the.
A Web site if you Google SBA at 19.
The second part of that is the paycheck protection
plan.
So that provides up to two and a half months
of payroll and it's a loan at 1 percent.
Now initially it was zero point five percent.
Now it's 1 percent.
But the loan can be forgiven if 75 percent
or more of the proceeds of the loan are spent
on payroll and your payroll does not decrease.
And individual banks are the ones processing
those applications.
And then the third component are just ordinary
Small Business Administration loans are called
7 8 loans.
And for new loans that are issued, the Small
Business Administration has pledged to pay
six months of principal and interest on those
loans.
And eventually you could get you could get
a loan that might be a two year loan.
And in the first six months, the that those
payments would be made for you and you would
not need to make that up.
Correct.
So theoretically, you could pay the principal
back after six months minus the the principal
payments that have already been made on your
behalf and you would not end up on any money
at all.
And of course, this is if you can actually
get the money disbursed, which seems to be
a question mark around all of these programs
right now.
Yeah.
I mean, I'll tell you that the ordinary SBA
loans are a little easier to get just because
banks make more money on that.
The interest rates are substantially higher.
The young people he loans.
And so banks, although the difference with
the 7a loans is that the banks do assume some
risk on that.
Usually from 25 to 50 percent or so.
So banks may be more reluctant and probably
will be more reluctant to issue those loans
right now.
We will continue keeping an eye on it.
And of course, as important as the small business
programs, the individual programs, unemployment
and the twelve hundred dollar deposits, which
we are continuing to try to raise, the question
marks around, but question marks certainly
remain.
Jason Goldwater's a California attorney.
Jason, thanks so much for talking to us and
explaining all of these different elements.
Thank you, David.
Best of luck to you.